bonjour à tous depuis lundi les
sénateurs examinent le projet de loi
nome portant nouvelle organisation du
marché de l'électricité la séance s'est
poursuivie hier jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin autour de l'article premier du
projet de loi
il faut dire que c'est l'article qui
apportent les plus grands changements
par ce texte
edf devra céder un quart de sa
production nucléaire à ses concurrents à
prix coûtant
afin de respecter les engagements pris
par la france envers l'europe
jusqu'ici ses concurrents comme poweo ou
encore direct énergie n'ont pas réussi à
proposer des offres compétitives
il faut dire que des eft à un monopole
en fait sur l'ensemble du parc nucléaire
français
à mes côtés le sénateur socialiste de
l'aude roland courteau
alors tout d'abord première question
qu'est ce que l'europe reproche
exactement à la france oui l'europe
formule un certain nombre d'exigences
est ce que je reproche à dire au
gouvernement et à la majorité en place
c'est de s'appuyer sur ses exigences
pour détricoter plus encore le système
énergétique français c'est-à-dire
d'aller plus loin encore que ne
l'exigent l'union européenne d'ailleurs
petite parenthèse l'europe n'a jamais
exigé de la france qu'elle privatise gaz
de france par exemple est justement
est-ce que vous pensez que cette arrivée
de la concurrence va permettre de faire
baisser les prix ou bien au contraire
que c'est la fin du tarif régulé
français c'est le dernier avatar d'un
processus délétère de libéralisation
c'est une étape supplémentaire
une étape supplémentaire dans la
libéralisation du système énergétique
français et je me pose la question à
quand le coup de grâce pour ce système
énergétique français à quand le coup de
grâce
alors quel est le problème aujourd'hui
le problème est la recherche
obsessionnelle de la concurrence or la
concurrence partout où elle a été mise
en oeuvre
ça n'a pas marché dans le monde entier
et en france ça ne marche pas davantage
6 % seulement des ménages sont passés à
la concurrence 12% des industriels sont
passés à la concurrence ça ne marche pas
ça ne marche pas parce que le secteur
électrique et un secteur à part
l'électricité n'est pas un bien comme un
autre et il n'est pas potable
donc ce secteur-là n'est pas compatible
avec les mécanismes concurrentiels alors
la trouvaille du gouvernement était de
dire berne va obliger edf à céder 25% de
sa production électrique
c'est une spoliation c'est une
spoliation du bien commun d'abord c'est
un petit peu comme si on obliger le
secteur public à subventionner le
secteur privé avec deux conséquences
gravissimes
la première la loi nome est une loi
d'augmentation des prix aussi bien pour
les ménages que pour les industriels
deuxième conséquence cette loi nome va
réduire les investissements de
production d'électricité
ça veut dire que ma crainte la plus vive
c'est que dans un certain temps notre
système énergétique qui nous est enviée
par le monde entier et qui depuis 1946
dans la pleine satisfaction à tout le
monde sait que notre système énergétique
connaissent des défaillances avec la
multiplication des coupures alors que le
projet temps exactement à la france on
reproche à la france d'avoir des prix de
l'électricité
trop bas c'est un comble et voilà que
depuis des années on nous cornes
y'a pas d'autre expression que il faut
aller à la concurrence pour faire
baisser les prix
et aujourd'hui on nous dit il faut
augmenter les prix pour permettre la
concurrence
je dis tout simplement qu'on marche sur
la tête et que lorsque les
sauf régis n'y a plus de limites merci
beaucoup à roland courteau d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
tout de suite retour à la séance d'hier
soir dans l'hémicycle très bonne séance
la séance et reprises
nous reprenons la discussion du projet
de loi adopté par l'assemblée nationale
portant nouvelle organisation du marché
de l'électricité dans la discussion des
articles sommes parvenus à l'amendement
numéro 158 au sein de l'article 1er
amendement 158 il est présenté par
monsieur donc par mon manager merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
donc c'est un amendement de repli qui
vise qui souhaitent nous souhaitons que
les fournisseurs qui demande un accès à
la reine justifie préalablement des
capacités d'effacement une production
requise à l'article 2 alors les
fournisseurs privés vont bénéficier
d'énergie à prix bas sans avoir
participé aux risques industriels et
sans contrainte en ce qui concerne les
consommateurs domestiques ou non lors
des débats en commission le rapporteur a
présenté l'article 2 comme la juste
contrepartie du sacrifice imposé à edf
l'article premier prévoit que dans un
délai de trois mois à compter de la
demande présentée par le fournisseur
alternatif un accord cadre doit être
conclu entre celui-ci et edf qui
garantit l'exercice du droit d'accès à
l'électricité de base du premier pendant
toute la durée du mécanisme
par la voix de contrats annuels cette
disposition entrera en vigueur dès la
publication de la loi afin de donner
plus de cohérence à ceux donnant donnant
nous vous proposons par cet amendement
de repli de conditionner la prise
d'effet de l'accord-cadre à la
justification par le fournisseur d'avoir
rempli l'ensemble des obligations
prévues à l'article 4 de nouveau de
l'article 2 du projet de loi
merci chers collègues la parole était
monsieur le rapporteur merci monsieur le
président chers collègues que l'on exige
des des futurs fournisseurs concurrents
ddf qu'il procède à des investissements
dans notre pays on le souhaite tous et
c'est même important et c'est une
condition qui est maintenant figure à
l'article 2 comme je l'avais dit tout à
l'heure
notamment ils demandent que nous avions
fait les deux rapporteurs de l'assemblée
du sénat au gouvernement qui a modifié
son texte son avant projet en ce sens
d'exiger que vous le demandez que ce
choix
préalablement à pouvoir disposer volume
de d'électricité au type de l'arenh
c'est pas possible
qu'est ce qui va se passer vous allez
favoriser ceux qui sont en place
le second producteur d'électricité en
france ces gaz de france suez notamment
grâce à la cnr le troisième c'est homme
ça veut dire et les autres viennent très
très très loin derrière ignorons si cet
amendement est adopté les autres
n'auront quasiment rien sauf peut-être
ceux qui commencent à investir
je suis allé il y à peu près huit mois à
l'inauguration de la première petite
centrale de poweo qui était cet état
puis à pont-sur-sambre une petite
centrale de près de 400 mégawatts
ils commencent à investir le direct
énergie vient d'inaugurer en moselle je
crois que c'est à sarreguemines je ne
suis pas sûr sa première centrale de
près de 350 mégawatts
une hotte est en début de construction
mais avant que ces nouveaux entrants
puissent disposer d'une capacité de
production et donc si on adopter votre
règle disposer de cet accès au nucléaire
vous ficher tous et vous privilégiez
ceux qui sont déjà en place point barre
ça veut dire que la production nucléaire
d'électricité
vous allez entre guillemets l'offrir à
gaz de france et sommes pour le moment
donc dans les jeux j'attire votre
attention sur l'effet pervers parce que
par delà sa votre votre choix est un bon
chemin
nous l'avons mis dans la loi il faut
laisser le temps à ces nouveaux entrants
d'investir construire une centrale à gaz
à fioul léger ça ne se fait pas du jour
au lendemain
voilà pourquoi il y a un délai dans la
loi c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous demande de retirer votre amendement
et 6,7 est si vous ne souhaitiez pas
retiré malheureusement je donnerais à
l'avis défavorable
merci monsieur rapporteur monsieur
ministre l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je vais donner le même avis évidemment
que le rapporteur vous demander si vous
le voulez bien de retirer votre
amendement ou alors un avis défavorable
pourquoi tout simplement parce que votre
amendement abouti en fait à repousser
l'application de cette loi à 2014-2015
pourquoi puisque dans le texte même de
la loi nous expliquons que pour juger
des capacités de production ou des
capacités d'effacement
il faut laisser le temps aux nouveaux
entrants de mettre en place comme il
l'évoqué le rapporteur l'ensemble leurs
outils construire une usine ça se fait
évidemment pas en deux jours
si on leur demande les obligations
d'effacement ou de production avant
l'application de leur droit à la reine
ça signifie que comme dans la loi nous
laissons trois ans après la publication
du décret pour mettre en place ces
obligations là on repoussa 2014 au mieux
2015 probablement l'application même de
ce texte c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vous demande de bien vouloir retirer
cet amendement
ou alors le gouvernement il sera
défavorable merci chers collègues même
source et ils retiraient il n'est pas
retirée pas de demandes d'explications
de vote
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le président de la commission
de l'économie sur l'amendement 158 2
donc l'eau et les membres du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et des
sénateurs du parti de gauche
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable que l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
156 du règlement
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront secrétaire un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
mettront un bulletin bleu ce qui soit
s'abstenir remettra un bulletin rouge le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
je
oh
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
non
jamais
ah ouais oui
à
bon
seulement
résultat du scrutin numéro 2 181 sur
l'amendement numéro 158 à l'article 1er
du projet de loi portant nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
nombre de votants 341 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 340 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 171 pour
l'adoption 153 contre 187 le sénat n'a
pas adopté
passons à l'amendement 159
il est présenté par madame search
présenté par le 159 madame mélanie si le
président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues par cet amendement
nous demandons que les accords conclus
entre edf et les fournisseurs privés
concernant la revente de l'énergie
nucléaire soit accessible au public
rappelons en effet que nous avons adopté
une loi en 2006 sur la sécurité la
transparence nucléaire et nous avions
convenu de manière unanime à l'époque
que l'acceptabilité du nucléaire reposer
sur la transparence
c'est pourquoi nous estimons que ces
contrats dont l'objet est la vente de
l'énergie nucléaire historique produite
par edf à des fournisseurs alternatifs
doit faire l'objet d'une publicité
d'autre part l'autorité de la
concurrence a estimé que je cite les
accords bilatéraux d'approvisionnement
conclu entre edf et un fournisseur
alternatif dans le cadre de cette
réforme pourrait avoir pour conséquence
je cite à nouveau de permettre ou de
faciliter les échanges d'informations
commerciales ou de prix confidentielles
entre les fournisseurs raison
supplémentaire pour que ces accords
soient rendues publiques sur le site de
la commission de régulation de l'énergie
c'est un monde ment n'engage pas le fond
et c'est vraiment le minimum que nous
puissions faire pour assurer la
transparence c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons d'adopter cet amendement merci
cher collègue monsieur rapporteur l'avis
de la commission
oui sa collègue moi je vous propose de
le modifier pour
il donnait un avis favorable je
m'explique faire figurer le contenu des
accords cadres à la fois je dirais ça
n'a pas forcément beaucoup d'intérêt en
plus ils sont tous conformes un modèle
arrêté par le ministre donc ça
n'apporterait pas grand chose ce serait
à dour il pourrait y avoir aussi
certaines informations
je dirais confidentielles en tous les
cas qui en termes du secret des affaires
il serait préférable de ne pas donné
qu'il n'y a pas de raison de donner au
public entre guillemets par contre par
contre que la liste de ces accords
cadres figurent sur le site de lacq re
pourquoi pas honte on mendie la
rectification que je vous propose au
lieu de mettre tous les accords cadres
sont intégralement publié sur le site de
la creuse je vous propose la liste des
accords cadres est publié sur le site de
la commission de régulation je dirais
c'est une amélioration en termes de
transparence et je pense que c'est une
information qui n'est pas inutile donc
si vous le modifier dans ce sens là à ce
moment là la commission vous donnant la
vie favorables c'est bon la liste des
accords cadres et publiée intégralement
on garde le la liste est publiée lors
c'est réaliste tu auras cui tous les
accords cadres bon la liste des accords
cadres elle se réfugier sur les chiffres
et la nation c'est une information qu'il
n'y a pas de raison de cacher au public
donc dans ce cas là ce sera un avis
favorable bon bah écoutez on est
d'accord pour cette cette modification
monsieur le ministre suite à cet accord
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je partage l'avis de la commission et
avec le sous-amendement je suis
favorable à l'amendement en question
pourquoi parce que le souci de
transparence que vous exprimez nous le
partageons
il faut de la transparence sur ces
accords cadres simplement si nous
publions l'intégralité de l'accord cadre
en question
il va y avoir notamment un élément c'est
les prévisions de croissance du marché
de chaque opérateur
qu'il ne me semble pas judicieux de
mettre à la connaissance de l'ensemble
de ses concurrents à partir de là si
vous acceptez le sous-amendement c'est à
dire la publication de la liste pour que
le public soit informé de qui a passé un
accord cadre
je vous rejoins et à sont là je donne un
avis favorable à landemont merci
monsieur le ministre
donc nous sommes d'accord pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien
levé la main je vous remercie il est
adopté à l'unanimité un amendement 59
rectifier il est présenté par monsieur
testons cet amendement vise à limiter
l'accès régulé à l'électricité nucléaire
historique que pour les fournisseurs qui
ont conclu avec edf des contrats leur
permettant d'avoir accès à l'électricité
produite par edf en se fournissant un
coût plus faible que celui du marché
ces contrats de long terme sont aussi de
fête des contrats de fourniture
ainsi de tels contrats existent entre
edf et gdf suez dans la cadre de la
centrale du tricastin à hauteur de 12%
entre l'allemand mbw edf dans la
centrale de fessenheim à hauteur de 17
points 5 % et entre edf et un consortium
suisse conduit par alpiq à hauteur de
15% à la centrale de fessenheim
également les droits de tirage de gdf
suez sur les centrales nucléaires de
choses et de tricastin ne représente pas
moins de sept 7 térawattheures obtenu un
prix inférieur à la reine il nous paraît
logique que ces droits soient décomptés
de la reine l'exposé des motifs du
projet de loi précise par ailleurs que
le dispositif prévoit de laisser la
possibilité de pouvoir déduire des
droits d'un fournisseur d'accès régulé à
l'électricité de base les quantités
d'électricité de base dont il
disposerait par le biais de nouveaux
contrats conclus avec edf
toutefois selon l'exposé des motifs
un tel mécanisme shit contribuera à
inciter edf et les fournisseurs
d'électricité
à conclure des contrats adaptés à
caractère plus industriel permettant le
cas échéant de mieux répondre aux
besoins des cocontractants que la simple
vente d'électricité à un prix régulé
ces contrats pourront par exemple
proposer un prix de l'électricité moins
élevé que le prix régulés en
contrepartie d'un partage du risque
entre edf et l'acheteur ou prévoit une
participation du fournisseur à des
investissements réalisés par edf en
citations cela nous concerne donc si
j'ai bien compris que les contrats
futures
il s'agit par exemple de celui de
flamanville 3 ou enel disposera d'un
contrat de fourniture de 12 5% sur la
future production
nous estimons que le calcul de la reine
doit également tenir compte du fait que
certains fournisseurs disposent déjà
d'un droit de tirage sur l'énergie
nucléaire d'une partie du parc
historique du fait de leur contrat signé
avec edf
tel est le sens de cet amendement merci
cher collègue monsieur le rapporteur
dont l'avis de la commission
merci monsieur président alors je pense
qu'il y à une petite confusion sur ses
contres en participation on a eu un
petit échange d'un désaccord sur le
terme utilisé quand je disais que
c'était une une participation capital de
centrales effectivement comme j'ai une
commission non le terme exact est un
contrat en participation par contre par
contre historiquement ce sont bien des
investissements qui ont été faits
pourquoi est-ce que gaz de france suez
est propriétaire d'une partie de
certaines centrales c'est parce qu'ils
ont investis dans cette centrale
en fait historiquement c'est pas tout
est fait ça qui s'est passé il ya eu des
échanges c'est avec electrabel à
l'époque c'était l'intérêt de gdf de
faire des échanges pour pouvoir disposer
de capacités de production est d'être
propriétaire autrement dit d'électricité
en belgique pour fournir des clients à
partir de la belgique en belgique en
allemagne en hollande en échange de quoi
gazin pardon c'est et electrabel à
l'époque c'est donc aujourd'hui gaz de
france suez avait était propriétaire
d'une partie de ses centrales et pour
alpiq notamment c'était aussi une partie
passion à l'investissement donc vous ne
pouvez pas je dirais créer une double
peine ils ont participé à
l'investissement
ils sont propriétaires de ces parts de
production
si vous voulez aujourd'hui déduire de
l'accès à cette électricité nucléaire
voulait pénaliser complètement il ya
aucune raison alors ça c'est pour le
passé pour l'avenir le ministre vous
êtes déjà répondu dans l'avenir il
serait très souhaitable que on n'utilise
pas la reine mais qui est bien des
contraintes des contrats entre edf et
ses nouveaux fournisseurs quelle que
soit la forme que ça puisse prendre et à
ce moment là je dirais il n'y a pas il
n'y a pas besoin de de l'évoquer non
plus ici en tous les cas de voilà chers
collègues je voulais surtout votre votre
amendement c'est pour parler du passé et
je crois que c'est une une erreur de
compréhension de la raison pour laquelle
une partie de ses productions
appartiennent à d'autres acteurs que
sont notamment alpiq
le n b w l'allemand et puis bien sûr gaz
de france suez donc je vous demanderai
de le retirer parce que ça n'est pas ce
serait particulièrement injuste à leur
égard sinon ce sera l'avis défavorable
merci monsieur rapporteur monsieur
ministre l'avis du gouvernement oui
monsieur le président un avis
défavorable à cet amendement pour la
raison suivante
en fait cet amendement est le premier
d'une série qui vont tous dans le même
sens des déductions sur les droits à la
reine
ça va être des déductions sur
hydroélectrique là ce sont des
déductions sur les participations aux
centrales existantes
nous y sommes défavorables pour
plusieurs raisons la raison principale
étant que dès lors que l'on souhaite
favoriser l'émergence de nouveaux
acteurs de nouveaux fournisseurs
il ne s'agit pas d'entrer de jeu de leur
couper une jambe en disant tout ce que
vous avez aujourd'hui ça compte pas et
on le d
oui des droits à la reine ce serait
totalement contre-productif par rapport
à ce que nous souhaitons à savoir
l'émergence de nouveaux champions
français et notamment l'émergence d'un
nouveau champion français pour avoir à
côté d'edf deux acteurs de taille
mondiale avec edf d'un côté j'ai déjà de
l'autre
or en l'occurrence dans cet amendement
lacets qui plus est gdf qui est
clairement visée puisque ce qu'il y à
suez electrabel bénéficient aujourd'hui
des participations que l'on évoque un
instant donc c'est vraiment la première
raison pour laquelle je suis défavorable
à cet amendement là comme je serai de
favorable à tous les amendements qui
vont venir sur les déductions de droit à
la reine en fait il ya une deuxième
raison deuxième réseau et une raisons
diplomatiques il ya des accords
diplomatiques à l'époque où il y avait
des monopoles comme le rapporte vient de
l'évoquer est donc cet amendement serait
en contradiction avec ces accords
diplomatiques
enfin un dernier point vous prenez un
risque avec cet amendement comme avec
tous les autres c'est qu'à partir du
moment où vous dites à quelqu'un
les droits que vous avez aujourd'hui on
va les déduire de la reine vous les
encourager à céder leurs droits actuels
pour bénéficier d'une part darren plus
importante
autrement dit au lieu d'organiser une
production vous désorganisé une
production très concrètement ça veut
dire quoi
je suis propriétaire aujourd'hui moi
petit producteur pour titre petit foule
n'aspire fournisseurs alternatifs d'une
petite centrale
on me l'a déduit de la reine le résultat
c'est quoi j'ai peut-être intérêt à la
vendre pour avoir une par darren plus
importante c'est pas incités à
développer des capacités de production
pour lee fait voler fournisseurs
alternatifs
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
défavorable à cet amendement
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
testons et il leur retirer
j'ai bien entendu les arguments
développés par le rapporteur et par le
ministre mais alors pourquoi dans
l'exposé des motifs du projet de loi
il est précisé qu'il y aura la
possibilité de pouvoir déduire des noix
d'un fournisseur d'accès régulé à
l'électricité de base dans le nouveau
dispositif que cette loi vise à mettre
en place
pourquoi deux poids et deux mesures je
ne vois pas pourquoi nous retirerions
cet amendement donc il ne sera pas
retiré
merci sa collègue monsieur courteau pour
explication de vote
oui tout à l'heure il a été indiqué que
l'on instauré une double peine en
l'occurrence là on pourrait dire on
instaure un double avantage juste une
remarque il est vrai que les
fournisseurs alternatifs ont investi ce
vrai mais il est aussi vrai que edf a
beaucoup investi et pourtant on oblige
edf à céder 25% de sa production
électrique
c'était juste une remarque au passage
merci chers collègues à d'autres
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement va
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veuille bien levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté deux
amendements identiques font l'objet
d'une discussion commune tout d'abord le
monde mon numéro 61 monsieur courteau
oui tel que tel actuellement rédigé cet
article prévoit qu'il reviendra à la
creux de calculer et de fixer le volume
maximal que des f devra céder à chaque
fournisseur
ce calcul sera effectuée en fonction des
caractéristiques et des prévisions
d'évaluation d'évolution pardon de la
consommation finale effective des
consommateurs finals que fournit le
contractant sur le territoire
métropolitain continental
c'est un amendement du rapporteur de la
commission des affaires économiques de
l'assemblée
je suis le noir qui a permis aux
fournisseurs d'obtenir des volumes
d'électricité au titre de la reine non
seulement en fonction de son
portefeuille actuel des clients qu'il
fournit mais aussi en fonction de ses
propres prévisions de vente autrement
dit de ses futurs et potentiels clients
et ce au nom d'une concurrence équitable
le rapporteur de l'assemblée précisant
d'ailleurs afin de permettre aux
fournisseurs alternatifs de
commercialiser de l'électricité dans une
situation de concurrence équitables il
est nécessaire de leur permettre
d'obtenir des volumes d'électricité au
titre de la reine en fonction de leurs
prévisions de ventes
autrement dit la commission de
régulation de l'énergie s'appuiera sur
les prévisions fournies par les
fournisseurs prévisions qui de fait ne
seront pas facilement vérifiable
évidemment puisqu'il s'agit de
prévisions pour l'auteur de l'amendement
monsieur le noir le dispositif de
complément de prix devraient suffire à
apporter toutes les garanties pour que
l'écart entre les prévisions et la
réalité des consommations ne présente
pas d'intérêt financier pour le
fournisseur
c'est lui qui le dit nous pensons au
contraire que rien n'est moins sûr la
prévision est un exercice extrêmement
difficile dans le contexte actuel par
contre une telle disposition risque
d'inciter les concurrents alternative à
multiplier le démarchage pour capter une
clientèle susceptible de changer de
fournisseur avec des publicités
particulièrement alléchante
par ailleurs nous considérons que le
mécanisme de complément de prix prévues
par cet article est au final très peu
dissuasif et que ce nouvel élément
rendra encore plus difficile le contrôle
des portefeuilles des clients
bref avec cet amendement nous proposons
de revenir si la disposition introduite
par le rapporteur de la commission des
affaires économiques de l'assemblée
nationale et qui permet aux fournisseurs
alternatifs d'obtenir
volumes d'électricité au titre de la
reine non seulement en fonction de leur
portefeuille de clients qui fournissent
mais aussi en fonction de nos propres
prévisions de ventes
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission
oui monsieur le président avis
défavorable
vous voulez figer une situation par
votre amendement qu'est ce que vous
dites vous dites que chacun des
fournisseurs concurrents nous dise quel
client français il a aujourd'hui et il
n'a pas le droit d'envisager de gagner
des clients dans l'année mais non c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe dans la
réalité ça bouge pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui et df n'a plus que 80 5%
de ses clients industriels
parce que ces entreprises sont allées se
fournir ailleurs ça bouge
les sujets sont pas plus figé en france
qu'à l'étranger et il faut il faut que
ça continue de bouger justement pourquoi
est-ce qu'il ya cette loi parce que
bruxelles lui reproche d'avoir un marché
qui n'est pas ouvert pas assez ouvert
donc pas votre un moment je le dirai non
seulement c'est contraire au projet de
loi nome
c'est contraire à la réalité les clients
eux mêmes les entreprises veulent faire
marcher la concurrence veulent faire
pression sur edf a dit aussi au mode
vous ne m'accorder pas meilleures
conditions je vais aller chez un
concurrent
c'est la réalité du marché ça c'est la
première chose que je voulais vous dire
sur un porteur je m'excuse de vous
interrompre mes jeux nous avions deux
amendements identiques et donc avant que
vous finissiez peut-être votre réponse
je crois qu'il serait bien que madame
didier présente son amendement merci
monsieur le président oui c'était c'est
exactement le même amendement
effectivement moins d'ailleurs par
rapport à ce que vient de dire notre
collègue j'ajoute que ce que je vois
aujourd'hui dans ma commune avec le
démarchage systématique des personnes
âgées qui naquit l'on explique
finalement c'est la même chose et qui a
pas de problème est qu'ils se revoient
tout à coup changer de fournisseur sans
qu'elle s'en rende compte
je me dis quand même il ya un problème
dans ce beau monde qu'on est en train de
nous créer mais bon je reviens à ce que
je disais là alors donc même
même amendement l'article premier du
projet de loi prévoit dans son alinéa 7
comment la commission de régulation de
l'énergie va partager le gâteau entre
les opérateurs privés
ce que c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit les
députés ont précisé à l'assemblée
nationale que les volumes darren seront
attribuées sur la base de prévisions et
nous nous demandons que ledit partage se
fasse sur les ventes réalisées est donc
avérée de l'opérateur privé
la question des nouveaux entrants pour
éventuellement soulever des problèmes
dans la mesure où leur accès alors est à
la reine est différée cependant les
conditions étant les mêmes pour tous les
opérateurs privés cette mesure ne serait
pas discriminatoire pour eux il nous
semble que le recours ou prévision des
fournisseurs sans aucune garantie
sérieuse sur leurs réalisations
constituent un élément trop incertain
dans la répartition envisagée et cela
d'autant plus que les sanctions prévues
restent largement ainsi insuffisant et
donc peu dissuasives le paragraphe 5
prévoit seulement un mécanisme de
régularisation
si le volume maximal d'électricité
allouées à chaque fournisseur au titre
de la rb calculé de manière prévisionnel
excède les ventes effectives constaté a
posteriori de ce fournisseur sur le
territoire métropolitain continental la
creuse devrait notifier aux fournisseurs
le complément de prix qu'il devra au
second en fait la sanction s'apparente à
une avance de trésorerie pour
l'opérateur privé c'est tout c'est pas
une sanction une avance assez
intéressante puisque et c'est un minimum
le complément de prix doit être au moins
égale à l'écart moyen entre le prix de
la rb et les prix observés sur les
marchés
alors quel prix qu'elle marchait à quel
moment
autant de questions sans réponse qui
pourtant conditionne largement la
hauteur du prix en effet à l'état actuel
du projet de loi il est renvoyé à un
décret en conseil d'état pour définir
les modalités
il est simplement précisé que le
complémentaire tiendra compte du coût de
financement lié au caractère différé de
son règlement et de l'ampleur de l'écart
entre la prévision initialement faites
par le fournisseur et la consommation
constatée de ses clients
ddd du client final le mécanisme de
régularisation qui vise à éviter les
abus en ce qui concerne l'évaluation des
prévisions nous sommes vraiment peu
performant c'est pourquoi nous vous
demandons d'adopter notre amendement qui
je le répète sera fera la même règle
pour tout le monde
merci j'ai un collègue monsieur
l'inspecteur vous avez vraiment
définitivement un terme
merci monsieur président oui je voulais
tout à l'heure je vous ai dit à propos
du premier rang devant 61 que je voulais
répondre avec deux précisions la
première c'est il ne faut pas figé je
veux dire c'est un marché évolutif et
c'est tant mieux
ils veulent ces amendements aurait pour
effet de figer totalement le marché
la seconde chose que je voulais préciser
le contrôle cher roland courteau mais
tout à fait facile à faire c'est un
contrôle qui est prévue en fin d'année
on verra bien en fonction des
estimations qui étaient faites par les
fournisseurs concurrents s'ils ont
effectivement eu les clients qu'ils
avaient annoncé en début d'exercice
il ya des sanctions si c'est une
situation inférieure ou supérieure
et alors cherilyn didier des sanctions
elles sont chères
moi je vous renvoie à l'article 7 comme
vous avez deux ce projet de loi
si vous avez des sanctions qui peuvent
atteindre 7% du chiffre du chiffre
d'affaires de ses fournisseurs voix 10%
c'est une récidive ce ne sont pas des
petites sanctions
je vous promets qu'ils vont faire
attention lorsque en début d'année ils
vont annoncer à edf ce que je prévois ou
halak revient sur ce que j'ai prévoit de
réaliser comme chiffre d'affaires c'est
ça et voilà le volume que j'aimerais
avoir ils vont essayer de calculer au
plus près et je crois que l'article 7
est une réponse à vos inquiétudes
concernant les sanctions
donc ma position est la même pour
l'amendement 160 que pour l'amendement
61 c'est un avis défavorable et chers
collègues
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre la vie de la commission l'avis
du gouvernement un monsieur le président
pour partager l'avis de la commission et
m 1
un avis défavorable pourquoi parce que
ce que nous souhaitons c'est encourager
les nouveaux entrants les fournit
nouveaux fournisseurs
et si vous fige est d'ores et déjà en
entrée de contrat en première année en
disant voilà vous avez d'oran en arène à
vos clients fin l'équivalent de vos
clients d'aujourd'hui vous n'en courrégé
pas ce marché là par contre là où je
vous rejoins c'est qu'il ne faut pas
qu'il prenne de la reine de façon
totalement déraisonnable c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous avez en fin d'année
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure un calcul
qui va être fait vous aviez demandé
temps vous avez eu tant de clients
vous avez demandé tant en trop la
différence vous la payer au prix du
marché et donc à ce moment-là ça
signifie qu'ils n'ont pas le bénéfice du
prix alain du prix de l'arenh sur le
trop plein de clients qui l'ont imaginé
ça me paraît un dispositif équilibré qui
les encouragent à des marchés d'un côté
et puis qui de l'autre côté
bien évidemment les sanctionne s'ils
n'ont pas respecté leurs engagements
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme
l'évoqué le rapporteur à l'instant je
crois que les nouveaux fournisseurs
calculeront au prix juste au plus juste
leurs besoins sur des données merci
monsieur le ministre
pas de demande d'explication de votre
explication de vote monsieur le cam
quelque chose qui m'amuse qui me réjouit
à la fois ces six vaudois ne fonctionne
pas messieurs les ministres
si les français se comportent comme ils
se sont comportés jusqu'à présent c'est
à dire que les entreprises restent
fidèles à l'opérateur historique
que va-t-il se passer est ce que
l'europe va vous punir une deuxième fois
est ce que vous allez aller négocier
encore plus bas ventre à terre devant
talent est-ce que c'est cela qui va se
passer
j'aimerais bien avoir votre opinion sur
ce sujet pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote si monsieur
courteau oui en fait une chose est sûre
1 nombreux sont les fournisseurs qui
vont être tentés de gonfler leur
clientèle potentielle moi je persiste à
dire est que
les abus seront particulièrement
nombreux vous voudrez bien et mais il
faudra bien que les sanctions les
contrôles d'abord et les sanctions
soient pour rendez vous on verra bien si
nous avons eu tort
merci chers collègues pas d'autres
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main il n'est pas adoptée ne
sont pas adoptées amendement 52,8
monsieur vrai nos plantes prix merci
monsieur présent nous avons défendu tout
à l'heure un amendement qui s'inscrivait
dans la même problématique que celui-ci
tout à l'heure il s'agissait de pendant
une compte dans le calcul et la reine
les contrats de participation de
fournitures que certains fournisseurs on
avec edf
maintenant il s'agit de limiter l'accès
régulé à l'électricité nucléaire
historique pour les producteurs qui sont
aussi producteurs en bazin nous
considérons qu'il n'y a aucune raison
comme fournisseur qui a aussi dans son
portefeuille de production de
l'électricité produite en base puissent
bénéficier de l'arenh
il semble tout à fait logique que l'on
puisse déduire de la reine électricité
en base dont il dispose lui-même
cela vaut évidemment pour l'hydraulique
au fil de l'eau il est bon de rappeler
que les grands concurrents d'edf en
l'occurrence gdf suez possède
pratiquement la moitié 49 90 % du
capital de la compagnie nationale du
rhône laquelle le produit 16 térawatts
ty d'hydroélectricité au fil de l'eau
lors de la prise de contrôle de la cnr
en 2003 le président dessus s insisté
sur le fait que cette production leur
site permettait d'être particulièrement
compétitif le marché français avec une
énergie produite à bas prix fin de
citation
on peut rappeler qu'en 2003 le coût de
production de racener était
effectivement particulièrement
compétitif puisque à l'époque les prix
des marchés du meuble de marché étaient
inférieurs aux tarifs réglementaires est
inférieure à 30 euros vous aurez du peu
ainsi le principal courte coupure edf
dispose d'une d'une grande quantité
d'électricité 8 térawatts soit une fois
et demi la production d'une tranche
nucléaire
de tricastin dont les coûts sont encore
sans doute inférieurs à ceux du
nucléaire historique est le rapport
annuel 2008 de la scène r préciser je
citais les ventes nettes d'électricité
on enregistre une très une très
importante croissance lié à la hausse
des prix elles s'établissent à plus de 2
milliards d'euros
cette performance est le résultat d'une
politique de placement optimisé sur les
marchés s'est déplacée placements sur le
marché de gros aux révélé cette année
encore leur pertinence
la cnr a pu profiter d'un contexte
particulièrement propice avec un prix
spot en augmentation de 67% fin de
citation le rapport précise et la
répartition des ventes 10% sur le marché
de détail 90% sur le marché de gros et
donc la majorité de la production
d'électricité à bas coûts est vendu sur
le marché de gros avec à la clé un
bénéfice très important pour leur
compagnie gdf suez il serait préférable
que nous centristes uriel qui vont voir
disparaître le tartam est le tarif
réglementé puissent bénéficier d'une
électricité compétitive plutôt qu'au
sein du si haye a limité les marchés de
gros merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de la
commission merci monsieur président oui
chers collègues bon dans votre exposé
des motifs vous avez clairement dit que
cet amendement visait la cnr et vous
avez raison puisque les autres
producteurs de base ce sont ceux qui
produisent de l'hydraulique et plus
particulièrement de l'hydraulique au fil
de l'eau je vous rappelle que bon la cnr
aujourd'hui ses caisses de france usb
ils ont acheté cet investissement au
départ c'est un investissement qui a été
réalisé donc vous voudriez pénalisé
celui qui investit entre guillemets même
si c'est un rachat d'un investissement
initial
si à ça que ça a que ça revient alors
dans la matinée on en a débattu en
commission vous le savez très bien
vous voulez pénalisé quelqu'un qui a
déjà investi vous voulez pénalisé
quelqu'un ou une entreprise qui paissent
à soult si je puis dire chaque année je
n'ai pas en mémoire le montant exact de
l'impôt sur les sociétés que paie la
ciat nerfs mais c'est une part dont 24%
de son bond qui est déjà sanctionné oui
mais bon le chiffre d'affaires non on
est d'accord 24% du chiffre d'affaires
donc c'est quand même une c'est quand
même assez élevé
et puis la dernière chose que je veux
dire bon je pense pas que ce soit le
moment de bouleverser ce qui valait de
toutes les façons dans pas très
longtemps
ça va faire partir les appels d'offres
sur l'hydraulique en france que ce soit
l'hydraulique au fil de l'eau que ce
soit les tout premiers qui vont être
remis en concession dès 2011
je crois que c'est notamment la dordogne
et quelques os de la zone pyrénéenne qui
va être remise en appel d'offres pardon
donc avant de bouleverser éventuellement
en ne permettant pas à gaz de
france-suez ça sert vient de pouvoir
disposer d'une partie de l'électricité
provenant de l'ue nucléaire en voulant
déduire ce qu'ils produisent otites de
l'hydraulique
je crois que attendons c'est pourquoi
une fois de plus les rendez vous prévus
dans cette loi sont des bons rendez vous
on verra notamment dans cinq ans et dans
dix ans
avis défavorable sur président merci sur
un porteur monsieur le ministre la vie
du gouvernement oui monsieur le
président même avec la commission c'est
un amendement important d'autres vont
suivre sur ce même sujet on l'a déjà
évoqué tout à l'heure toute une série
d'amendements qui vise à déduire de la
reine des droits existants
ce correspondant à la cnr ce concours
correspondants tout à l'heure
o participation dans les centrales bref
des amendements qui visent à réduire la
base de la reine pour un certain nombre
de fournisseurs et notamment pour le
deuxième champion je reviendrai sur les
trois arguments que j'ai utilisé tout à
l'heure un nous souhaitons l'émergence
d'un deuxième champion français de
taille mondiale
première chose 6e d'ores et déjà on lui
dit sur l'accès au nucléaire de base on
vous coupe une jambe en déduisant ce que
vous achetez ce que vous avez déjà on
ampute de ses capacités premier point
deuxième point là encore je ré exprime
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure vous
allez pousser ceux qui ont déjà de la
production vous avez poussé à se
désengager leur production pour avoir
droit à plus darren hoare ce que nous
souhaitons tous collectivement c'est que
ces nouveaux entrants et bien évidemment
s'engage investissent dans des
productions nouvelles
c'est la raison deuxième raison pour
laquelle je serais défavorable à cette à
cet amendement
enfin dernier élément mais je ne pas
répéter ce qu'a dit le rapporteur
je crois qu'il est important aujourd'hui
de considérer que pourquoi il ya cet
échange asymétrique qui peut paraître
déséquilibré à l'encontre d'edf
parce qu'aujourd'hui qui fixe les prix
du marché en france
quelle sera la référence pris la
référence prix ce sera évidemment la
production des f pas la production des
fournisseurs alternatifs aujourd'hui
c'est la troisième raison pour laquelle
que si vous considérez qu'il faut
déduire les productions actuelles par
exemple de gdf c'est que vous considérez
qu'ils ont un impact sur les prix ce qui
n'est pas le cas puisque seuls
aujourd'hui edf a une position telle en
termes de production d'électricité notre
pays que seul edf impact sur les prix
voilà les trois raisons pour lesquelles
le gouvernement est défavorable à cet
amendement comme à ceux qui suivront sur
ce sujet là merci monsieur le ministre
pour explication de vote monsieur
courteau oui
après réflexion puis c'est vrai que nous
avons eu lieu également eu des
entretiens
multiples avec des représentants
derrière de la cnr et c'est vrai qu'il
ya la fameuse taxe de 24% également sur
le chiffre d'affaires tout cela réuni
fait que nous allons le retirer je le
président l'amendement
merci chers collègues m il est donc
retiré un amendement 56e rectifier il
est présenté le 56 pas rectifié monsieur
courteau non monsieur testons monsieur
raoul monsieur merci monsieur le
président c'est amendement vise en fait
est ce que le coût préférentiel de la
reine soit répercutée sur le
consommateur final comme bien comme ça
vient des dit d'ailleurs par monsieur le
ministre
et en l'occurrence qui nous préoccupe le
plus c'est que ce prix soit répercutée
en particulier pour les industriels je
n'oublie pas les ménages etc
il s'agit là de la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
aujourd'hui quelle est la situation
en théorie les industriels qui
bénéficient du tartam cher à neutre à
porter donc dans l'extinction est
programmée fin 2010 pourront continuer
grâce à la reine je l'espère à
bénéficier d'une électricité d'origine
nucléaire à un prix inférieur à celui du
marché de gros mais en pratique on
voudrait s'en assurer et pour ceux ci le
dise nous vous proposons cet amendement
en effet le dispositif de la reine est
prévu pour une période transitoire de 15
ans soit jusqu'en 2025
quant aux tarifs réglementés bleu vert
jaune pour les plus gros consommateurs
c'est à dire certains industriels
il ne serait maintenu que jusqu'en 2015
c'est à dire dans cinq ans après 2015 je
crains que ce ne soit le chaos
une fois que le tartam aura disparu une
fois que les tarifs réglementés
n'existeront plus faut pas se leurrer
rien ne vient nous prouver que
l'électricité nucléaire sera encore
accessibles à des tarifs acceptables
les industriels qui viendront se fournir
en électricité nucléaire chez les
fournisseurs alternatifs ne peuvent pas
être les perdants de cette réforme
la répercussion du tarif préférentiel de
la reine doit être perceptible
d'ores-et-déjà pour nos industriels qui
ont des visions à relativement long
terme et doivent être orientés vers
l'ensemble des coûts de fourniture de
production d'un provisionnement
commercialisation comme vous le prévoyez
monsieur le rapporteur à l'article 4 il
y va de la compétitivité je le dis de
nos entreprises et pour éviter une
succession de délocalisation liés à
cette réforme chère collègue monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission
oui cher collègue roland courteau
merci monsieur le président vous vous
exprimer un souci vous exprimer pardon
l'amendement est un amendement roland
courteau et c'est toi daniel qu'il a
défendue je m'excuse le ceux qui tuent a
défendu composition sais c'est la
crainte finalement que les entreprises
paient leur électricité trop cher demain
bon juste deux choses que je veux dire a
priori le la reine sera bien sûr très
proche du tartam
c'est bien ça l'objectif nous le savons
tous en même temps et vous l'avez
exprimé sur vauban
mais nos collègues de la majorité rohos
ils ont exprimé
nous voulons tous que cette entreprise
nationale qu'est et df puis-je continuer
à être un fleuron industriel majeur et
dans notre pays et à l'international
d'où la difficulté très bien présente et
de trouver un juste prix
je suis d'accord ça n'est pas facile
c'est la première chose que je veux dire
la deuxième chose pour le consommateur
final domestique
cette loi est bien précises elle dit que
le tarif régulé est maintenue pour le
particulier
on est bien d'accord il n'est pas
question de remettre en cause donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
qu'il est oui oui pour le moment dans
notre le texte du vaucluse examine
aujourd'hui sur lequel nous avons nous
pouvons nous prononcer c'est la raison
pour laquelle je considère que il est
inutile de rajouter ce que propose cet
amendement et que je donne à l'avis
défavorable
merci monsieur rapporteur monsieur le
ministre la vie du gouvernement même
avis monsieur le président aime avis
défavorable les explications de monsieur
bourque un jeu je pense que cet
amendement et a toute son importance
la question sera est ce que demain on
aura on va s'aligner sur le prix
européen où est ce qu'on va garder nos
prix concernant l'électricité
je viens d'écouter le rapporteur il n'y
a aucune garantie
il ya aucune garantie et on nous dit
effectivement on devrait le prix de
l'arenh sera sue du tartam mais il n'y a
rien de précis
et quand on fait une loi on est prêt si
non je pense ça se passe comme ça
à partir de là je me dis que ça peut
être un espace intéressant pour
différents spéculateurs qui vous le
savez dans le débat qu'on a eus
précédemment vont acheter l'électricité
et tout à l'heure le secrétaire d'état
nous dire qu'il pourrait le vendre sur
le marché européen on ne pourra pas le
contrôler on ne pourra pas le contrôler
et maintenant on nous dit ouvertement
qu'il n'y a aucune garantie pour les
particuliers dans le moyen terme mais
surtout aucune garantie pour nos
entreprises concernant le prix de
l'électricité
je le dis comme je le pense franchement
ça peut être une prime à la
délocalisation si on continue comme ça
pourquoi faire des états généraux de
l'industrie si ensuite on augmente
sensiblement le prix d'électricité
mais mme lagarde a déjà dit qu'il
augmenterait environs de 10% il vient
d'augmenter
il ya peu de temps
hélas ce que nous a dit monsieur le
rapporteur nous amène à la plus grande
prudence
et ce qui est demandé à travers cet
amendement ce sont des garanties des
garanties vous savez le faites nous
confiance
on verra ça sera peut-être le prix de
l'arenh tout ça c'est des suppositions
tout ça c'est des suppositions demain
quand le consommateur payera il aura
raison de s'en prendre ce qu'ils ont
fait la loi et demain quand les les
industriels délocaliseront parce que
comme ils nous l'ont dit dans la vallée
de la maurienne
si le prix de la xt trop cher ils feront
ils feront leur production ailleurs
notamment en chine où il ya 22 pour 22
fois le pauvre couler du silicium ou
couler de l'aluminium 22 fois le le coup
en co2 alors voilà sont des questions
fondamentales et l'amendement présenté
par daniel raoul a toute son importance
je pense vraiment vraiment qu'il n'y a
aucune garantie dans cette loi on est
dans le flou le plus absolu
comment rester dans le flou le plus
absolu alors je sais je chante ici la
réponse qui va nous est apportée fait
confiance aux marchés devraient tous
réglés nous font confiance à la loi
merci chers collègues pas d'autres
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre mais bien
levé la main
il n'est pas adopté un amendement numéro
il est présenté par monsieur sergent
merci merci monsieur le président est
cet amendement va dans le droit fil de
celui que vient de développer
daniel raoul t marseille dont
l'explication de vote a été fournie par
martial bourquin
il est des plus simple il consiste à
préciser que le volume d'électricité
nucléaire historique céder aux
fournisseurs en fonction de leur
portefeuille
deux consommateurs est exclusivement
réservé à ses consommateurs finals pour
le dire autrement le volume est destiné
aux consommateurs qui ont précisément
servi au calcul du droit à la reine
l'étude d'impact jointe au projet de loi
ne dit d'ailleurs pas autre chose je
cite les volumes céder aux fournisseurs
alternatifs seront déterminés en
fonction du rapport entre la production
nucléaire du parc de référence et la
consommation effective des clients
situés sur le territoire français raison
pour laquelle il est sans doute aussi
précise et plus loin je cite toujours de
manière progressive les consommateurs
bénéficiant aujourd'hui des tarifs
réglementés devrait se tourner en partie
vers les fournisseurs alternatifs ce qui
permet sans doute aussi à l'étude
d'impact de conclure sur les effets
bénéfiques attendu de la nouvelle
concurrence permettant aux moyens et
gros consommateurs de ne pas subir les
prix fixés sur les marchés de gros je
cite encore le dispositif permet de
pérenniser la maîtrise de la facture
d'électricité fonte et sur la réalité
industrielle des coûts compétitifs de
production du parc de référence non
exposées aux aléas des prix de marché
européen ceci étant dit avec notre
amendement on est tout à fait sûr que ce
sont les consommateurs finals clients
des fournisseurs alternatifs qui
bénéficieront de la reine nous serons
sûrs que l'électricité à prix coûtant de
notre parc nucléaire historique
mise à disposition des fournisseurs
alternatifs
n'ira pas alimenter de gros
consommateurs au delà de nos frontières
ni faire l'objet de valorisations par lé
trader sur les marchés internationaux de
gros ou sur leur marché spot cher
collègue monsieur rapporteur l'avis de
la commission
merci monsieur président oui chers
collègues le le dispositif mis en place
n'exclut pas ceux qui ont une activité
de trading
je vous rappelle que d'ailleurs bien sûr
que non df l'entreprise edf
je crois me souvenir que lorsque
monsieur proglio est venue devant nous
en commission nous a avoué que
l'activité de trading d'edf alors pas
france seuls tout europe confondus était
de palu et non le siège est à londres
mais l'activité trading concerne toute
l'europe le siège d'ailleurs il ya deux
ans trois ans nous avions été
quelques-uns aller visiter le central de
trading ddf à londres ce qui était très
intéressant de mémoire il nous a dit que
c'était de l'ordre de 900 millions
d'euros
enfin c'est une activité très importante
et donc il n'est pas question de
d'interdire l'accès à cette électricité
nucléaire pour ceux qui ont une activité
de trading par contre à l'article 2 il
est bien précisé que ceux qui ne font
que ça ne pourront pas disposer de de la
reine donc je pense que ça suffit
largement il n'y a pas besoin d'ajouter
ce que vous proposez d'ajouter à
l'article 1er c'est les raisons pour
lesquelles je donne un avis défavorable
1,6 sur l'inventeur monsieur le ministre
de la ville et aux errements même même
avis demandes d'explications de vote
il n'y en a pas que ceux qui souhaitent
adopter cet amendement avait bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui sont contre
eux veulent bien levé la main il n'est
pas adopté un amendement 233 rectifié
bis il est présenté par monsieur amoudry
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
les dispositions actuelles de l'article
un grand troyes limite au 31 12 2015 la
prise en compte des catégories et du
profil de consommation des clients du
fournisseur seul implique qu'à partir de
2016 certains usages particuliers tels
que les activités saisonnières
par exemple l'exploitation de remontées
mécaniques ne bénéficieront que très
marginalement voire pas du tout de
l'électricité nucléaire alors que de
manière factuelle devraient avoir accès
à cette énergie
les centrales nucléaires produisant
globalement plus en hiver pour s'adapter
à la courbe de consommation française en
effet les fournisseurs alternatifs de
ces entreprises ne pouvant disposer que
de très peu voire pas du tout d'énergie
nucléaire pour ces usages saisonniers
leurs offres resteront intégralement
définies par les prix de marché et ces
entreprises devront en conséquence
consentir un coût élevé pour leur
approvisionnement en électricité
par ailleurs gdf restant seul à utiliser
une part de production nucléaire pour
fournir ces entreprises l'opérateur
historique disposerait d'un avantage
compétitif se traduisent en soit par une
offre à prix plus faible que la
concurrence soit par une offre à prix
équivalent à la concurrence mais avec
une marge plus fortes ainsi en l'état
certaines entreprises touristiques ne
pourraient pas bénéficier des effets
escomptés du projet de loi c'est à dire
une concurrence accrue des fournisseurs
ainsi qu'un accès aux ressources du parc
nucléaire produite dans notre pays
l'objectif de cet amendement est donc de
remédier à ces inconvénients tout en
limitant la façon de prendre en compte
les profils de consommation puisque
seulement trois niveaux de puissance
différents dans l'année serait
d'identifier cela permettrait de ne pas
réduire la détermination des volumes un
simple ruban sans toutefois engendrer
des volumes vendus d'électricité
nucléaire qui augmenterait anormalement
le volume global de la reine merci cher
collègue monsieur le rapporteur l'avis
de la commission
merci monsieur président oui en
commission nous avons demandé l'avis du
gouvernement pour la raison suivante
bompas cet amendement chers collègues
vous voulez revenir sur le caractère
transitoire jusqu'au 31 décembre 2015 de
la prise en compte des catégories et du
profil de consommation des clients afin
de refléter la modulant
sion de la production des centrales
nucléaires c'est bien l'objet le
gouvernement a accepté cette modulation
de la reine au cours des premières
années du dispositif mais ne souhaite
pas qu'elle aille au delà du 31 décembre
je vous rappelle simplement chacun que
nous avons ce rendez vous tous les cinq
ans le premier rendez-vous est justement
2015 et je pense que ce sera le bon
moment de entre guillemets voir où on en
est et voir s'il est opportun ou non de
prolonger la modulation donc je souhaite
qu'on garde au rendez vous de 2015 et
donc a priori qu'on ne retienne pas
votre proposition et c'est la raison
tous les cas pour laquelle je fais
confiance à ce rendez vous je vous
demande de retirer l'amendement
monsieur le ministre la vie du
gouvernement
j'ajoute en outre qu' il ya une question
spécifique comme il en assure la sncf
enfin on assemble de poids spécifique
qui ne peuvent pas faire l'objet d'un
traitement d'ordre général vous savez
que représentant des remontées
mécaniques ont été reçus vendredi on à
nouveau rendez vous le 4 je pense qu'on
doit pouvoir avancer sur ce sujet
indépendamment d'un texte dense général
par ailleurs je souscris à la position
générale du rapporteur
merci monsieur ministre chers collègues
et ils retiraient
je remercie tout d'abord leur ministre
d'avoir organisé la la réunion récente
avec le secteur professionnel je veux
souligner qu'il s'agit d'un secteur dans
lequel les activités
contrairement à une idée répandue sur
extrêmement fragilisée et où l'élément
coût de l'énergie est tout à fait
déterminant pour 36 raison que nous
pouvons tout à fait concevoir la
concurrence ainsi que les aléas qui
tiennent aux conditions de température
et c'est donc c'est un domaine qui est
extrêmement fragile et je voudrais que à
travers le propos du ministre puissions
avoir des garanties d'une je dirais
d'une sécurisation de ce domaine à cette
condition je serai prêt à retirer
l'amendement mais j'aimerais quand même
qu'on puisse avoir des références et et
un engagement tout à fait non pas d'y
travailler mais en engagement sur un
objectif
alors avant d'avoir la réponse du
ministre monsieur récents pour
explication de vote avant que le
président bédié les ministres puis leur
apportera j'ai eu l'occasion
d'intervenir des géants commission sur
cet amendement
je souscris complètement est ce que
vient de dire notre collègue amoudry je
pense que il faut plus que des garanties
il faut bien comprendre que la période
de transition n'a pas beaucoup d'effet
sur le problème que nous posons période
de transition peut servir ailleurs mais
là je serais tenté de dire qu'au bout de
cinq ans ce sera trop tard
c'est on peut pas assimiler le problème
qui a été posée par cet amendement à la
période de transition je crois que cette
période ne réglera en rien le problème
qui est posé il faudrait au moins que
les entreprises concernées aient accès
aux rubans et à la production
d'électricité nucléaire pour que l'on
puisse au moins avoir cette garantie
pour que c'est un moment sont retirés
dans de bonnes conditions
si j'avais monsieur paul explications de
vote
oui l'amendement qui est présenté là ne
fait que décliner localement un problème
que nous avons évoquées concernant
l'ensemble des industriels pour qu'ils
bénéficient du tarif de la reine c'est
exactement de la même logique
et je ne comprends pas qu'on fasse des
traitements sncf monde remonte pente et
c'est dans nos dans le dos du
législateur on voudrait savoir
d'ores-et-déjà et donner un message
industrielles avec une vision à cinq ans
quel est le tarif dont il bénéficie
grand cd stratégie c'est pas du jour au
lendemain qu'un industriel va arrêter
certes mais quand même ils ont besoin
d'avoir un plan un business plan etc à
au moins cinq ans et on est dans le flou
le plus complet
je veux bien qu'ils aient des
traitements spécifiques concernant les
industries que vous évoquez qui
effectivement sur les consommateurs
intensif enfin mais c'est l'ensemble des
industriels c'est vrai pour l'aluminium
c'est vrai pour les équipementiers
automobiles c'est vrai pour l'éclairage
enfin je comprends pas très bien qu'on
puisse avoir des discussions dans le dos
du législateur sur des problèmes
spécifiques et qui concernent l'ensemble
en fait des industriels merci chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
je réponds bien volontiers premier point
il n'y a aucun souci jusqu'à 2015
les exploitants dont vous parlez aucun
est au tartam où ils sont tarifs
réglementés ils y restent où ils sont
aux tarifs libres et la situation
actuelle ne va que s'améliorer
donc j'ai entre maintenant et 2015 il
n'y a pas de difficultés particulières
au delà de 2015 c'est tout le débat que
vous
devant à voir avec ça mais
indépendamment de la règle générale nous
avons des cas particuliers le l'objectif
d'un gouvernement d'une nation c'est de
traiter les cas particuliers nous avons
le problème de la ratp nous avons celui
de la sncf où nous avons celui de cette
activité qui par nature consomme l'hiver
et pas le reste de l'année
pour dire les choses simplement et qu'il
ya une véritable difficulté s'il ya un
espèce de taux moyen annuel
donc on en est parfaitement conscient
c'est pour ça qu'on a cette réunion ces
réunions qui sont prévus pour trouver
une solution qui peut être soit une
seule une solution par arrêté ou par
décret de mutualisation avec des
activités qui sont en sens inverse
mais dans tous les cas de figure il faut
pas que la loi préjudicie d'aucune
manière mais il faut garder le texte
général
merci monsieur luise cher collègue
monsieur le président je ne voudrais pas
polariser le débat sur la question des
remontées mécaniques mais je voudrais
simplement rappeler que imaginer que la
perspective d'après 2015 ira vers une
meilleure fortune nous ne le ferons pas
croire à ces exploitants qui voilà
quelques années ont été démarchés à qui
on a dit sortez du marché régulé aller
sur le marché libre pendant deux ans et
qu'ils ont gagné quelques petits nous
quelques gains et depuis ils ont induit
un delta extrêmement défavorable entre
le prix de marché et les prix régulés
donc sur cette perspective là
malheureusement on ne peut pas je crois
qu'on peut difficilement avancer et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
qu' il faudrait que nous puissions avoir
une garantie absolue que ces entreprises
aient accès aux rubans nucléaire à la
base nucléaire le ministre
ils vont bénéficier de l'arenh demain
donc ils vont ils vont avoir à faire un
tarif inférieur de toute façon si le
souhait du quota aux tarifs de marché
actuelles le problème particulier deux
hivers étaient va être traité dans le
cas d'un accord qu'on va passer avec eux
mais le principe général de la situation
actuelle ils vont pouvoir bénéficier du
tarif
donc il n'y a pas de difficultés
particulières de décor on en prend
l'absolu engagement l'amendement est
retiré il est retiré un amendement
numéro 55
il est présenté par madame ni coup sûr
le président de ce ministre et chers
collègues le rapport de la commission
champsaur a considéré que l'accès à
l'électricité nucléaire historique était
nécessaire au développement d'un marché
concurrentiel de l'électricité en france
les fournisseurs alternatifs auront donc
accès à l'électricité compétitive du
parc nucléaire historique
il n'en demeure pas moins que ces
fournisseurs disposent depuis plusieurs
années de l'entière liberté d'investir
dans des moyens de production électrique
de semi base
il est dès lors indispensable dans le
souci de favoriser le développement
d'acteurs industriels contribuant de
manière responsable à la sécurité d
approvisionnement électrique du pays
qu'ils soient dès à présent fortement
incités à développer leurs propres
capacités de production pour parvenir à
cette incitation industriels l'accès
régulé à l'électricité nucléaire
historique doit être limité à court
terme à la seule électricité de base
correspondant à la fourniture d'une
puissance constante tout au long de
l'année
le présent amendement propose par
conséquent qu au delà de la période
allant jusqu'au 31 décembre 2015 ou la
modulation des centrales mentionnés au 2
est prise en compte dans l'accès régulé
à l'électricité nucléaire historique
seul l'électricité de base soit concerné
par l'accès régulé à l'électricité
nucléaire historique
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission
merci monsieur président oui nous avons
déjà évoqué ce sujet à deux reprises
chers collègues c'est bien sur l'article
2 qui traitent du sujet qui est celui de
l'obligation pour les fournisseurs
alternatifs d'investir dans la
production ou dans dans l'effacement
je pense que cet article est suffisant
en l'état et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous demande de bien vouloir
le retirer sinon ce serait un avis
négatif
merci monsieur rapporteur monsieur
ministre l'avis du gouvernement mais ma
vie mais chez le président même avis
alors andy coup et ils retiraient il
n'est pas retirée pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main l'amendement
n'est pas adopté un amendement numéro 60
il est présenté par monsieur courteau
oui monsieur le président afin de
garantir le caractère transitoire du
mécanisme d'accès régulé au nucléaire
historique
il convient d'organiser la décroissance
progressive des volumes d'électricité
auquel ont accès les fournisseurs pour
alimenter leurs clients seule la
perspective de cette réduction
programmée de l'accès à la production
nucléaire d'edf est susceptible
d'inciter les fournisseurs concernés à
développer leur propre approvisionnement
par l'investissement direct dans des
moyens de production ou par des accords
industriels avec d'autres producteurs
en revanche comme l'affirment l'avis de
l'autorité de la concurrence sur le
projet de loi
l'absence dans la loi de tout dispositif
organisé de sortie de l'accès régulé à
la production d'edf par une décroissance
des volumes conduire est un échec du
dispositif avec dans l'intervalle un
coût important pour la collectivité
aucun opérateur
nour est en effet intérêt à investir et
la sécurité d'approvisionnement serait
ainsi mise en péril nous proposons que
cette sortie organisée des buts à mi
chemin de la durée du dispositif soit le
1er juillet 2018 et qu'elle s'effectue
de manière progressive et could avance
sur les dernières années du dispositif
nomme si chacun est bien monsieur
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission
merci mais je président alors je partage
le même souci que l'auteur de cet
amendement que notre collègue roland
courteau
je crois que tout le monde est d'accord
le gouvernement l'a répété à plusieurs
fois tout le monde est à caen sur le
fait qu' il faut que ce dispositif à
rennes ne soit se dirait que transitoire
et que progressivement on en sorte par
caen dès aujourd'hui dès 2010 m que
c'est à compter du 1er juillet 2018 que
le volume d'électricité attribue à
chaque fournisseur dans le cadre de la
n3 doit décroître je considère que c'est
trop tôt nous avons des rendez vous et
notamment le premier qui arrive en 2015
le second sera en 2020 2025 peut-être
que c'est l'année qu'il faudra que nous
mettions peut-être qu'au moment de ce
rendez-vous 2015
nous leur ajouteront à ce texte de loi
peut-être que en fonction de là où nous
en sommes nous je dirais conseilleront
d'attendre encore cinq années plus avant
de fixer la date exacte à partir de
laquelle le volume décroître a
systématiquement sur le principe oui
sur le moment non c'est trop tôt c'est
la raison pour laquelle chers collègues
je vous demande de le retirer ou sinon
ce serait un avis défavorable
si monsieur rapporteur monsieur le
ministre la vie du gouvernement oui
monsieur le président c'est un débat
important que nous avons eues en
commission que nous avons aujourd'hui en
séance publique
c'est la question la dégressivité
des droits à la reine je crains que si
la haute assemblée a adopté cet
amendement
elles aboutissent à l'effet exact
inverse de celui qui est recherché et
probablement même à une augmentation des
prix
pourquoi tout simplement parce que à
partir du moment où vous réduisez la
reine
ça veut dire que les fournisseurs
alternatifs voyant leur par darren
diminué pour pouvoir fournir leurs
clients seront obligés d'aller les
chercher leur électricité sur le marché
prix du marché qui est très largement
supérieur au prix de l'arenh et donc
sera évidemment des conséquences pour
leurs clients à savoir une augmentation
des prix qui leur sera fournie premiers
éléments me semble-t-il pour lequel je
crois il nous faut être défavorable à
cette à cet amendement
deuxième élément quel est l'objectif
poursuivi par cet amendement c'est de
dire il faut pousser les autres
fournisseurs à investir c'est déjà prévu
dans le texte de loi puisque suite
notamment à l'intervention des deux
rapporteurs assemblée sénat
avant même le texte ils nous ont
convaincus d'avoir cette obligation de
production en face elle est donc
aujourd'hui dans le texte l'obligation
de production simplement aujourd'hui les
besoins qui seront exprimés probablement
à partir de 2015 2020 sur la
prolongation des centrales
ce sera d'aider si ce seront des
décisions qui seront prises dans le
cadre du programme pluriannuel
d'investissement probablement après la
clause de revoyure de 2015
il me semble qu'il faut corréler les
sorties à la reine il faut les corréler
obligatoirement aux nouvelles décisions
de production j'ajoute enfin que
mécaniquement la part de la reine dans
l'électricité d'aider des différents
fournisseurs va diminuer mécaniquement
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'à
partir du moment où nous développons des
énergies notamment renouvelable la part
du nucléaire français
va baisser dans la part globale de la
production d'électricité autrement dit
les droits à la reine sur l'ensemble de
la production d'électricité française
diminuera mécaniquement par rapport à ça
c'est donc pour ces trois raisons la
queue que je propose plutôt un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
notamment pour l'effet mécanique qu'il
aura sur les prêts si monsieur le
ministre il est patent que le dispositif
tel qu'il est construit ne va pas
inciter les fournisseurs alternatifs à
investir j'ai l'impression que ça m'a
plus ou moins d'accord là dessus ils ont
là qui leur est assurée comment non je
parle de isotopes un biberon qui leur
est assuré et dès lors ils ne prendront
pas le plus petit risques industriels ou
financiers pour investir
c'est clair certes j'ai bien lu que
l'alinéa 34 précise que le rapport du
gouvernement proposera avant le 31
décembre 2015
le cas échéant je dis bien le cas et
chiens on regarde c'était évaluation des
modalités de fin du dispositif
je cite toujours assurant une transition
progressive pour les fournisseurs
bon d'abord ce n'est qu'un rapport de
plus rien n'est sûr car ce sera le cas
échéant où ce sera en fonction d'eux or
ce qui est sûr et c'est écrit d'avancé
c'est que les alternatifs n'est
investiront pas dès lors notre
amendement annonce dès maintenant à ses
fournisseurs
la couleur ils sont déjà prévenus à
compter de 2018
le volume de la reine va décroître si
vous n'investissez pas ce sera doses que
nous proposons un sevrage progressif
noon ou nounou mouleur à l'ensemble
d'ares ans pour qu'ils prennent toutes
leurs dispositions
donc ça veut dire en clair n'attendez
pas de
1015 préparez vous dès maintenant à
investir le jackpot ne durera pas
éternellement merci chers collègues
la parole est à mme sur raul pour
explication de vote monsieur le
président si j'ai bien écouté monsieur
le rapporteur et ça correspond en fait à
l'idée en tous les cas qui est
sous-tendue par cet amendement c'est
qu'il s'agit bien de dire que le
biberonnage c'est un terme qui vous
convient pas monsieur le rapporteur
mais c'est bien ce que nous nous
comprenons c'est sera un jour et que le
sevrage devra s'organiser et donc qu'on
le rédige à partir d'une date fixe qui
sait le 1er juillet 2018 au qu'on dise
que c'est date sera fixée après leurs
rapports ou la clause de revoyure de
2015 ça revient exactement même dans
l'esprit
moi je veux bien qu'on fasse un combat
sur la date de 1er juillet 2018
mais ce qu'on est d'accord sur le fond
que ce sevrage devra s'organiser à une
date qui est proche et qui sera qu au
mieux 2015 et au pire peut-être 2020
mais à partir du rapport qui aurait été
fourni en 2005 par le gouvernement
est ce que c'est bien ça sur lequel on
est d'accord collègues je dérive débat
pour explication de vote
je vais tout à fait dans le sens mais
d'une façon ma m'exprime monde peu
différemment puisque effectivement cet
amendement propose une sortie
progressive de la reine par le biais
d'une réduction graduelle du volume
d'électricité met à disposition des
fournisseurs
cette réduction ne débutera d'ailleurs
qu'à la moitié de la période transitoire
afin que les nouveaux acteurs du marché
puisse y trouver leur place alors je
dirais que pour ma part que c'est une
disposition à la fois simple efficace
qui mérite en tout cas notre attention
elle est simple parce qu'elle annonce en
quelque sorte en amont les règles du jeu
d'une concurrence qui ne sera plus alors
organisez artificiellement au seul
profit des fournisseurs et efficace
parce qu'elle constitue
à mon sens la meilleure incitation
possible pour encourager les
fournisseurs investir dans les capacités
de production ce qui a été dit à la fois
par roland courteau et par daniel raoul
donc au vu de ces éléments
cet amendement me semble donc tout à
fait indiquée puisqu'il rappelle
opportunément que la concurrence à des
exigences dont les fournisseurs
alternatifs ne serait en tout cas dans
tout état de cause se dispenser dont je
vote aurait personnellement cet
amendement merci chers collègues je
voulais rectifier leur nom allez-y je
vous en prie monsieur comme témoin
puisque on est je crois d'accord sur
l'objectif nous proposons alors je le
texte ne change pas sauf à partie de la
deuxième phrase cette fraction décroître
à chaque année à partir d'une date fixée
à la suite de la clause de revoyure de
c'est l'esprit puisque les l'accord
formalisé cet accord
si je reprends exactement cette fraction
décroître à chaque année à partir d'une
date fixée à la suite de la clause de
2015 monsieur le rapporteur
attendez je suis pas madame soleil
je sais pas non mais attendez certains
d'entre vous avaient exprimées parfois
avec une certaine virulence des doutes
sur le fonctionnement de ce cette arène
que nous allons instaurer
c'est vrai que c'est un système complexe
je ne sais pas moi non plus si ça
fonctionnera bien ou pas bien et je les
dis depuis le début je m'en suis jamais
caché
c'est pour ça que ce rendez vous de 2015
est un rendez vous important
il n'y a pas besoin de mettre cette date
aujourd'hui le rendez vous est très
important nous verrons bien ce qui
marche et ce qui ne marche pas et nous
verrons notamment bien c'est la priorité
et daniel tu as très bien exprimé
j'aimais compris ton intervention
on souhaite tous que les fournisseurs
alternatifs investissent vous venez de
suivre les discussions autour du projet
de loi nome portant nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
tout de suite preuve par trois michel
grossiord reçoit bruno le maire le
ministre de l'agriculture
vous pouvez aussi retrouver toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
sur notre site internet
www.public.fr très bonne soirée sur
notre chaîne